[Music]
what happened today in washington dc
is not american the rampage of the
capital
yesterday was a disgraceful act and it
must be
vigorously condemned this is a very
distressing time in the united states
and
i feel terribly for what's happening
there i really do
that's how some u.s allies are
responding to the riot at the u.s
capitol that drew attention around the
world yesterday
other global leaders are criticizing
president trump and his supporters more
directly
as holly williams reports from london
holly what are they saying
good morning well the british prime
minister boris johnson described the
scenes in washington as
disgraceful the german chancellor angela
merkel said she was sad
and angry and said she regretted that
president trump hadn't accepted defeat
and the swedish prime minister said that
president trump bears significant
responsibility
for an assault on democracy to be clear
those are american allies
calling out the leader of the free world
more or less directly for this
attack on u.s democracy and that i think
is unheard of but it's not just
america's friends that are watching this
unfold it's america's rivals and enemies
iran's president said this shows what a
failure western democracy is
a russian spokesperson said the cause of
the quote
split in american society is an
electoral system that doesn't meet
modern democratic standards and we'll
see more of that in the days to come
from dictators
authoritarian regimes and
authoritarian-minded leaders
who will almost certainly use what has
happened they will use it to accuse the
us of hypocrisy
for criticizing other governments when
its own system is in turmoil
and they'll say to their own people look
american democracy is not a model for
the rest of the world it's chaotic
and this just shows that you need an
authoritarian like me
the fact is the united states is a
cradle of democracy
and when american democracy is rocked it
sends
shock waves around the world yeah holly
as
former acting cia director mike morell
said yesterday it gives ammunition to
our enemies
some people have compared this to civil
wars and coups even in other countries
you've covered
both of those does this look in any way
similar to you
uh no it does not i mean it looks
dangerous and and destabilizing
and and unsettling and i'm not trying to
downplay
any of that at all but the military has
not
seized control of the government which
is so often what you see in a coup
uh armed gunmen have not seized control
of the media that's another thing that
you often see
and while there's been deadly violence
it's nothing like on the scale that we
see in countries that have
spiraled into civil war holly williams
in london thank you holly